let's unbox the new iPhone 15s we've got
the smaller iPhone 15 and the iPhone 15
plus okay we're gonna unbox the pink one
first because I've decided executive
decision this is my desk my rules and my
knife is pink thanks Jerry rig
everything
this pink color is so pretty oh check it
out oh my gosh I'm so hyped about it I
could cry we've got this new braided
cable do we have a sticker is it gonna
be pink
it's not I got so hype it's just a
regular white so here's the pink let's
take a little look at it
oh
minty I'm not gonna lie at the Apple
event I didn't really pay attention to
any of the other phones except the pink
one so I didn't really get hands on with
any other colors this is very very
pretty I love the way that all of the
colors just look so nice together like
everything is so cohesive so so pretty